en octobre dernier le procès avait été
reporté cette fois l'audience aura duré
plus de huit heures à l'issue un
réquisitoire un an de prison avec sursis
et une interdiction d'exercer la
profession de gendarme pendant cinq ans
pour l'un et de manière définitive pour
l'autre pour la victime
c'est un peu de soulagement je crois
qu'aujourd'hui considérer qu'il doit y
avoir une interdiction d'exercice à
titre définitif c'est ce sont des
douanes réquisitions en tout cas je
pense qu'elles peuvent satisfaire la
partie civile il y retrouve une l2
grande instance de paris
comparer c'est un adjudant et un
maréchal des logis de la brigade de
joigny dans l'yonne
aujourd'hui suspendus de leurs fonctions
il aurait entre octobre 2012 et novembre
2013 prononcé de nombreuses remarques à
caractère sexuel à l'une de leurs jeunes
collègues tout juste affectés dans la
brigade la jeune femme en souffrance
annie plus d'un an avant d'en parler à
sa hiérarchie les victimes militaires
malheureusement sont des jeunes femmes
qui sont en situation de précarité
professionnelle
donc elles hésitent à dénoncer des faits
parce qu'on va leur reprocher ensuite et
bien d'avoir créé un trouble dans la
brigade d'avoir nui au bon
fonctionnement de l'unité et ça peut se
retourner contre contre elle à la barre
les prévenus on nier une partie des
faits pour le reste il s'agissait selon
eux uniquement de plaisanterie de
mauvais goût
alors pour l'un des avocats de la
défense la peine demandée par le
procureur est difficile à entendre
ça me paraît inadaptée parce que malgré
tous un bon gendarme voilà donc
oui ça me paraît inadapté l'afer a été
mise en délibéré le tribunal rendra son
jugement le 5 avril